a crewless transoceanic ship using ai
powered automation
ibm db2 click to containerize and the
new hybrid subscription advantage
program
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all
my name is ian and i am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements from ibm cloud
i want to start this week with the
amazing story of the cruelest ship that
is attempting to cross the atlantic
ocean
without human intervention with ibm as
its exclusive technology partner
promer built the mayflower autonomous
ship to navigate the high seas using
intelligent automation
with artificial intelligence the ship
analyzes real-time sensor inputs
decides and performs automated processes
and collects data to support marine
science
with the absence of human crew promere
and ibm needed to extensively design
test and develop the ship's brain
nicknamed the ai captain
to effectively detect process and decide
how to navigate the ship
additionally to sense surrounding
environmental conditions and make
informed decisions without connecting to
onshore systems
ibm's edge computing technology manages
15 edge devices to process data onboard
there is so much more about this
groundbreaking voyage than i could
possibly cover in this brief segment so
make sure you hit the link in the
description of this video
to get the latest info about the
mayflower's trip
next up i'd like to introduce a new
service called ibm db2
click to containerize that is going to
fast track your database journey to red
hat openshift
click to containerize enables you to
inspect the database review and change
any required settings
and then move it into your hybrid cloud
environment running openshift
or ibm cloud pack for data best of all
there is no need to import
export decrypt or expose any of the data
within your database
but click to containerize is not just
limited to migrations
it actually supports many different
containerization scenarios
including simplified database upgrade
cache containerization
and cloning and existing service to
learn more about how to get started with
ibm db2 click to containerize
see the link below to wrap things up
today
i want to talk a bit about the new
hybrid subscription advantage program
this program allows customers who have
already purchased ibm cloud pack for
data software
and system platforms to automatically
qualify for substantial discounts
on ibm cloud pack for data as a service
let's say you use an on-premises db2
database as part of cloud pack for data
but now you no longer want to manage
that on-premises database
instead you prefer to migrate your
environment to a fully managed db2 on
cloud database
with the hybrid subscription advantage
program you could leverage your existing
investment in cloud pack for data
by transferring on-premises software
licenses
in doing so you'll obtain a significant
discount on equivalent cloud managed
services
via ibm cloud pack for data as a service
to take advantage of the new program
today hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered
make sure you explore the links in the
description of this video and again
please don't forget to subscribe to our
channel to stay up to date on what's
going on in the cloud
now
you